did you know a new Texas law might make
it illegal to impersonate Elvis Texas
lawmakers said their so-called drag ban
was meant to keep kids away from
sexually explicit events but laws like
this are so vague they can end up
Banning a whole bunch of things that
have nothing to do with drag shows like
a High School production of hairspray or
this female Elvis impersonator it's a
classic example of why most restrictions
on Free Speech are not just
unconstitutional but also totally
impractical what is that special that
Texas drag law aband sexual
gesticulations using accessories that
exaggerate male or female sexual
characteristics the problem is the law
doesn't Define sexual gesticulations so
according to a new lawsuit the law could
apply to this or this
or this it doesn't matter what
politicians want to do it matters who
the law actually does and government
regulations almost always have
unintended consequences